天天收钱，假装别人的。
最好的朋友大郎一般都是最好的朋友嘛，best friend嘛。
他他每天假装自己最好的朋友。
然后收钱。
看起来很潇洒，但其实他每天花钱呃收钱做别人的朋友，他实际上。
他是一个收钱出卖友情的人，他实际也没有友情，明白这个意思吗？
他的你的也是友情。
等于我所以我说这是为什么这个这个戏是一个友情戏爱情戏，对吧？
就他的腻的也是朋友。
所以。
你去看打点，你仔细再把顶制伴郎看一遍，只看比故事。两个人第一次。
开始有点恍惚了，觉得真的像好朋友一样了。然后开始提醒说，我们可不是朋友，我们是雇佣关系。过了婚礼之后，我们。
老死不相往来，对吧？然后第一次灵魂拷问，对吧？这个这个。
你你你这个你不是收钱当他的伴郎吗？你感觉就是这个黑人不是感觉自己很潇洒吗？但是被人反问了一句，说你如果结婚，你的伴郎是谁？
对吧你他妈也没朋友呀，你以为你比。
那些可怜虫厉害吗？你收他们的钱，你也没有朋友，你要结婚的时候，谁给你当伴郎啊？
对吧就他的B故事也是点的相当完整，相当有层次。一步一步两个男人的感情升温。哎，这就是所所说的这就是我们所说的，有时候B故事是感情线。
对不对？
你看这个庇股史不就是感情线吗？
就这两个男人实际上是需要对方的，需要友情的，需要交个朋友的。所以A故事虽然是雇佣关系。AA故事是这个小胖子雇佣那个黑人来假装我的好朋友是这个雇佣关系，但是B故事是感情线，是这两个人友情的。
不断。
发生发展。
结果。
所以这就是AB故事，明白啊？从定制八郎的角度。
我们还看了一个前天看的那个摇滚校园。
摇滚校园。
摇滚校园是一个落魄的摇滚歌手，开场就证明就说他那个那个被自己的乐队给踢出来了，对吧？因为也不咋地，然后表演也不成功，然后落非常落魄的摇滚歌手。
嗯。
寄宿在朋友家里，意外得到一个，其实是那个电话是找他朋友去那个学校去去当临时老师代课老师。但是他因为特别缺钱，他就把这个事儿给截胡了。截胡了之后，他就去一个学校当老师。他本来想在那瞎混嗯。
这个这个这个把这个钱挣了就行了。然后后来他就发现咦这些学校里面的小孩这是个贵族学校啊，贵族学校的小孩那都是你知道课余活动，那都是搞点大提琴啊、钢琴啊什么的，对吧？跟咱们跟咱们这一样啊，就有钱人家的孩子都学乐器嘛。然后他看这小孩都回乐器。
然后他就萌发了一个想法，我把这些小孩组织起来，教他们摇滚的那套东西，他们反正有音乐的底子，然后呢带着他们去参加。他本来是想去参加一个比赛的，有2万美金的奖金，他带着这帮小孩去参加比赛，等于又把这个代课的钱挣了，然后呢又能在说不定在那把那2万美金坑到手里。
这就是A故事。
对吧我们能讲出来的就是A故事。
闭护式是啥？
庇护室。
是这个男人。
一步一步。
成为了一个更好的。
摇滚歌手更精准更正确的理解并传达了摇滚精神。
我们从忘的逆，哎，这个稍微有点难理解了，对吧？我们从忘的逆的角度，我给你剖析下，你就不觉得难了。
我们说他本来是的望，他他的原始欲望是什么？
他的大愿望。
我们说他有个大欲网。
大渔网是。
我们说在want need之上啊，它要有个大欲望啊，每个都是这样啊，每个故事都这样，它有个大欲望，大欲网就是成名。
成名头二啊。
他大愿望是不是成名成二，天天吹牛逼，说我要在多少人面前演出，我要怎么着怎么着摇滚啊，这个他的大欲望是成名成万。
大药很原始啊。
猴子也能理解呀，出人头地猴子能理解。
他的大鱼王是成名虫外。
然后那他在A故事里面的w针对这个欲望的w是什么？
在A故事里面的w。
就是就是呃参加比赛呃，忽悠这帮小孩跟我参加比赛，把那个钱挣了，然后能出名，还能签签公司，对吧？那那比赛都是一个套路，说你得了第名，能签公司嘛，跟咱们中国的选校一样。
就是他就拿这个忽悠你，然后他就支持他的外在望他。
它内在逆的是什麼？
他的欲望是成名成万，那他的逆的是什么？
他实际的内在需求是什么？
呀，白天慢呀。
在这里就是be a better rock singer。
你成为更好的一个摇滚。
越手牙。
你想要成名成万，你要成为一个更好的摇滚人。
更好的摇滚。
这这个音乐音乐人。
所以他慢慢的理解了，你去看这个B故事，你如果怀呃你这个为B故事，你去看他的打点。
他在什么时候动哇，这就是摇滚精神。哎，我可以教孩子们摇滚啊，摇滚不就是要传播爱吗？传播能量吗？
我传播给你们不一样吗？然后小孩朋友说，那我们就叫摇滚学校吧，他就对我们就叫摇滚学校。
对吧然后小孩子开始摇滚，由于开始摇滚接触的摇滚歌手会跟其他的摇滚歌手在那儿。
打牌呀，那些妖哥都有带。
在呼一些东西，飞叶子。
然后那他就开始制止，对吧？很就是维护摇滚的正能量，剔除摇滚的负能量。
他就成为了一个。
更好的摇滚。
更具有摇滚精神，他更正确的理解了摇滚精神了，不是成名成外。你只要。
成为一个更好的摇滚歌手，所以他内在需求是成为更好的摇滚歌手。你以前你乐队为什么把你踢出来，不是欺负你，是你真的不优秀。
对吧是你真的不够优秀。
小蝌蚪，你不要老埋怨池塘里，人家都不搭理你，欺负你。
你是不是自己有问题呀？
对吧你成天借着你没有妈，成天在那装哭而卖惨，对吧？啊，我没有妈妈，你们欺负我没有妈妈，你欺负我，你没有妈妈，这件事情我们早忘了。
我就是因欺负你是是因为。
你确实让人讨厌，你知道吗？所以就是就是这个意思。这个这个我们说我们这个男主。
他上来很惨嘛，被乐队踢出来了。
我们从A故事角度肯定是同情他的，觉得他太欺负了。从B故事的角度，你你是不是。
确实就是唱的不行啊。
老板说小刘啊，到我办公室来一趟，对吧？老板要开除你呀。
你你可能就是差，不是老板欺负你。
明白这个意思吗？
明白这个意思吧？就摇滚校园相对于刚才我我们看过的其他几个片子来说，摇滚校遥的B埋的更深。
比埋的更深，但是也很清晰，也很完整，你也能拎出来理一下。
好吧，这就是我想给大家补充的AB故事，然后它对应的want和逆这件事情。
我跟你说啊，其实want和你就是这个AB故事啊。
玩的最狠的是什么呀？
玩的最狠的还是星爷。
周星驰。
你如果有这个AB故事的这个思维了啊。
卑鄙故事的思维。
给你们想几个例子啊。
就是星爷把AB故事往往是拉的最开的。哎，我刚才给你们举例子的时候，你们应该感受到了啊，就是说AB故事它往往是。
虽然病驾齐驱，在同样的事件里面，有时候在同一个事件里面既挂上A又挂上B了。
我们就想象一下，它是两根横轴啊，A和B并驾齐驱，对吧？你外在的事情在怎么经历，你的内心历程是怎样的？两个轴。
然后呢。
但是它一高一低，你们发现了吗？就一明一暗，明着是A，暗着是B。但是呢A往往就就是从品格的角度来讲啊，A是有点low的。
啊是吧鼻呢往往是昂扬的。
昂扬的。
然后呢所以其实应该反过来A在上呃，B在下面，A在下面啊，你怎么理解都行。我的意思是啥呢？你看啊周星驰有很多片子啊，他的AB呀。
也是兵大齐虚，但是是这么兵大齐曲，就拉的非常之开。
啥意思呢？就是他的A极其卑微。
B极其雄壮。
极其雄伟。
我们说星爷是无厘头的，他搞的都是。
大喜剧。
所以他就敢玩的那么大。
他实际上的行为它实际上这条AA的故事线极其小。
极其卑微，极其生活。
但他的鼻呢经常是。
拯救世界。
普度众生。
普豆众生真的吗？是普豆众生啊。
我们说功夫。
功夫啊。
功夫他最后成佛了。
功夫里面他是一个小痞子，他的A故事是一个小痞子，想要在社会上打拼，成为一个牛逼哄哄的人，欺负人收保护费是他的A故事，对不对？
是他A上面的历程。
他在。
他在笔上。
这是什么？
你想要真的成为别人的偶像，真的呼风唤雨，真的。
牛逼的话，不应该是斧头邦那种路子。
是应该是佛祖那种路子，对吧？他最后那个功夫你们忘了吗？从天而降，他就变成如来神掌嘛？他变成如来的呀。
而且他你狠狠的点了一下题，他关于他普度众生火云邪生问他这是什么功夫啊？
他直接他直接回答什么？
想学吗？
教你。
他普渡众生，他连魔鬼都可以普渡。
他连魔鬼都能普渡，都能引渡，都能原谅。
这就是狠狠那个点普渡众生的题。
小痞子辅助众生。
他的鼻骨是往往极其雄壮。
他就是说他的庇护史这个内心历程，这个人物胡光啊，他拉满拉足，而且拉的十分夸张。
十润夸张。
对吧九匹芝麻官那个苏乞儿苏乞儿最后统领天下丐帮比皇帝。
统领的人都多，而且皇帝还跟他说，你你统领这么多人，你要是造完怎么办？他怎么说的？
他说你要是个好皇帝，我就没有人同类了。
对吧。
度众生啊。
动终生。
然后那个。
我们说特别代表周星驰呃，这个这个自有点像自传的这个喜剧之王。
集剧作。
对吧他的A故事是。
想成名成万。
呃，一个小小的特别小的这个这个群众演员，小群演，社会底层小人物。
他的A故事是一步一步的。
想要演主角当明星。
对吧先先要混一个正脸，再混一个有台词，再混一个主角，对吧？然后再当明星，当大腕儿，跟那个莫文蔚那个那个角色抱人家大腿，当当明星。
对吧。
这是A故事吧。
他的闭故式是什么？
B故事上我们说也很完整，有几个大点的地方。
开课。
教表演。
当老师。
对吧虽然是因为A股市场缺钱。
但是他对于B故事来说，他已经开始。
奉献了。
已经开始。
帮助别人了。
对吧他上课。
然后呢，又。
嗯，劝妓女从良。
想拯救张柏芝。
然后我们说B爱情呃感情线也是逼故事上的事儿嘛。
和张柏芝是有爱情的呀。
是有爱情的呀。
这也是逼估市场爱情。
拯救，而且想拯救他不上班行不行啊？
对吧我养你啊。
他就是想拯救他呀。
然后到最后。
呃，到又到后期。
拯救那个黑社会。
那个那个他们街坊那几个小痞子呀。
街坊那几个小痞子记得吗？
收保护费的那几个。
他也拯救了他们，带着他们演话剧，对吧？
他跟他说什么？
他就是说你。
那个他跟那个黑社会说。
你不是英雄。
你成天喊打喊杀，你不是英雄。
你奶奶一个人把你带大。
他是英雄。
对不对？
然后他到最后还做什么事儿？
他在街坊的人，他在街坊的话剧社终于做成了。
他把文艺他把艺术，他把正能量，而且他演的是什么？
他演的是纯真。
我们中国人不是东亚病夫那场戏。
他把正能量传达给民间。
在像在这个这个社区剧场。
组织这帮。
失足青年。
体制和妓女呀，这不是十足青年吗？组织着十足青年。
表演最正能量的戏。
传达给最底层的百姓，我当什么明星啊？
这就是他的B故事。
是不是我们说喜剧之王有点像周星驰自传。
体的一个电影。
普度众生是他。
终极目标。所以我们你看我们去看这个这个星爷的创作啊。
他的A护士极其卑微。
他永远是极其卑微的一个A故事。
但他的逼骨史普度众生，极其宏大。
证明了。
对这个创作者内心。
一定是极其分裂，及其。
纠结极其孤独的一个一个人，他一定是非常孤独的。
一定非常孤独的，才会走这么大的极端。就是他的A故事。
永远是从最卑微。
送过外卖被人大被人山捡破烂。
功夫里面那个那个少林足球里面捡破烂儿。
被人欺负被人打。
穿的那么破的鞋，就是它永远A极其卑微。
但是他的B。
还要当佛祖。
他要普渡众生，他要拯救所有人。
他一个人都不放过，他全都要拯救。
所以说。
青爷为什么这么孤独？就是说他心里扛的事儿确实多，这个人非常孤独。
他那天就写这么极端的东西。
好吧，这里说多了啊，一说兴叶，这个这个喜剧庄说多了。
回到我们的课上，我们要学什么来着？
学AB故事。
AB故事是两条线。
A上驱动的是want。
鼻上取动的是逆的，一个是外在的，一个是内在的。
好吗？
我们说用的时候，我刚才给大家说过，我说很多创作者。
我我把这里擦一擦啊。
哎不，大家肯定记了，没记的话，可以倒到前面去，这就是上网课的优势，对吧？我不用担心板书没有保存啊。
我稍微差差一点地方出来给大家说一下这个啊，就是我刚才给大家说，我说那个那个有很多人在写的时候啊，他的那个故事线啊。
他是把AB分开写的。
嗯。
也有那种特别复杂的啊，就是说。
我们经常我经常说我写句的时候，你拉一个横轴嘛，对吧？在横轴上打点啊，呃，那个A故事到哪了？就是说A故事对吧？我们的主角先干了什么，再干什么那干什么就么一场戏，A故事是一条线。
我们说呃既然我们有AB股式的思维了。
呃，是有一些创作者习惯把笔。
也写一遍呢，就说A这些事儿你都写完了，你这个B你需要单写打点。有时候A上的事儿不够用，你要往上补的。
有时候可以借A上的事儿，比如说A这里有一件事儿。
AA的这条线上有一件事儿，你发现这件件事儿也适合作为B的。
比如说作为B的起点，我们就说30分钟那个事儿，30分钟是B的起点嘛，人物湖光的起点在30分钟。
30分钟的时候，这件事情在A上面是A的一件，比如说是A。
呃，在A股市里面。
也也发生了，那么你就把。
在A股上，比如说有件事儿，但是呢你需要在B股市上，他遇见，比如说遇见张柏芝。
遇见那个那个那个感情线的另位，或者遇见王八，小蝌蚪遇见王八，对吧？周星驰遇见张柏芝，那就放你就把笔这件事情安在上面。然后有时候呢在这里，比如说你需要把笔往往上再提一下，在笔故事上，你需要再补一个，然后你发现这里没有对应的事情，那你也可以单写。
但是呢你是需要把完整的鼻这条线单拎出来的。
我是指这个意思。
就是AB单写是这个意思，就是在你的构架上单写。还有人。
就是还有人是4条线单写。
A故事B故事还有什么？我其实之前说过人物关。
人物关系单写，就有些戏人物关系复杂，所以他把人物关系单写，就是说这个两个人的感情。
那个相知相识呃，误会破裂，呃，相杀，然后呃死一个什么的？反正就是人物关系这条线也有人是单写的。但是我这我讲这个的时候，我是在电视剧那集那刻讲的，就是电视剧啊，一般这个事肯定是要单拎出来的。
因为电视剧的人物关系比较复杂，也比较有搞头。因为你要这个这个电视剧长啊，你不搞人物关系，你撑不了那么长，所以就一般把人物关系单写。电影的话啊这个见仁见智了。
特别是大部分电影这个主角，即便是多主角，但是它也是一个行动。
就是我所我说的所谓的假多主角啊，就是说虽然看起来好几个主角，但是他是一个行动，一个行动员，一个一个一个一个主事件，一个一个动机。
所以他不存在大的人物关系，他们当中当然有这个这个这个沈腾黄渤在这个前进过程中，在这个疯狂的呃外星人。
这种呃沈能黄官在这个共同的行动中会有几个的时候，但那还不构成人物关系，根本就不构成人物关系。
所以在大部分电影里面，这个是有是不需要单写的。但是我见过有极端的人啊，四条线A故事B故事，人物关系也单捋一遍，然后还把什么单捋一遍啊，还把那个那个价值。
或者叫主题主题和价值单另一边，就是正负价值啊。我们说正负价值不是有个battle吗？
就一会儿正价值占优，一会儿负价值占优。
就是正正负价值的此禧彼伏，以及最后的正价值大获全胜。
还有把那个单拎出来。
也有啊，人家就是就是那种。
对，就是好莱坞有有有一有一套教程，他是这么搞的。
就是把这个分的特别细，但我感觉唬人的成分大一些。在实际运用当中啊，我感觉。
呃。
一个电影的话，你把AB分开捋一遍还是很有用的。
然后对于一个电视剧的话，你可以尝试把人物关系。
单独理鱼一条线索，便于你。
呃，宏观的控制整个戏的节奏，对整个戏有个你更有更有效率的一个把控。
所以大家知道一下这些方法，自己去揣摩，自己去运用。好吧，这节课我给大家补的就是关于这个AD故事。
我为什么补呢？是因为我觉得它还是很有用的，确实是很有用的。好吧，他们对应的这个want和ne呃。
就是多说这么几句下课吧，正式下课了啊。